joining me now is our security and
defense editor Deborah Haynes and
Deborah we're hearing more about the U.S
operations to get its staff and their
families out of the country just tell us
more about that and indeed how the
British operation is going to get staff
out and also other British Nationals
like razan whom we've just heard from
yes so the US has said that they've
evacuated just under a hundred people
from Sudan that is all of the U.S
Nationals who work at the embassy and
other U.S staff they've left the local
Nationals in place to keep the embassy
open in terms of the actual operation
it's incredibly high risk this is a very
volatile situation on the ground you've
got two warring factions still fighting
there's no secure Airfield to land and
the U.S said that they sent in a special
operations team using Chinook
helicopters they flew from a base in
Djibouti which is a country close to
Sudan where the US has a large military
base and the helicopters refueled in
Ethiopia they then actually didn't throw
a few they refueled in another country
in yeah in Ethiopia and then they landed
in Sudan they were only on the round for
an hour as these officials were put onto
the helicopters and then removed from
the country the helicopters were not
fired upon that's clearly something that
the planners of an operation like this
would have to be taking into
consideration it's it was very high risk
they've managed to get out but it really
does underline the huge challenge facing
all countries that have officials
diplomats in Sudan at the moment that
they need to get out Saudi Arabia and
Jordan launched operations yes the day
before to to get their people out and
that included through the port in the
east of the country the red Seaport
again it's there's no freedom of
movement and so for ordinary citizens
like the person you've just heard from
it's incredibly difficult they are being
advised to stay in place
um we understand that the UK does plan
to to evacuate its diplomats from Sudan
as soon as feasible but the government
hasn't said how that's going to happen
they've said that their the foreign
office and the ministry of Defense are
working on a number of different
contingencies of course there's the
possibility of launching their own
mission as the US have done to get
people out they could do it in a
coordinated way they could also ask
allies to help the uh the British
diplomats but for the British Nationals
that are in the country the advice
remains to stay in a place of shelter
the UK does say that its top priority is
to help those British Nationals but
those words aren't going to be a huge
amount of comfort for people that are
unable to leave and at the moment don't
seem to have a viable evacuation option
being offered but of course that could
change because the situation remains
incredibly volatile and for the UK it's
clearly a high priority the Prime
Minister chaired his fourth Cobra
emergency meeting yesterday morning on
the crisis which really does underline
just how serious it's serious it's being
taken but also given the fact that
there's been no movement so far it would
seem just how difficult it is to be able
to conduct operations in Sudan at the
moment